My diet recommendations, you said, to stay away from bone broth because it's high in glutamine
and also to stay away from high histamine foods.
I'm trying to heal my gut right now and I'm looking at a vegan pea protein that contains glutamic acid and histidine.
I'm not sure if they're the same as glutamine and histamine.
Well, histidine is not the same as histamine and glutamic acid will convert to glutamine.
So you could say glutamic acid and glutamine are the same, histidine and histamine are not the same.
But so you can't use this so I wouldn't do that.
Now, if a person, okay, so should every cancer patient stay away from glutamine in their supplements?
The answer in my book would be yes.
Unless the person is in a state of, you know, their cancer is in a state of remission.
They've been doing really well and they want to do glutamine to heal their gut for a short period of time.
That I'd say that's, I'm sure you're most likely going to be fine with that.
It would be, you know, contraindicated if the person is going to go on a glutamine supplement for a longer period of time.
Now, most good practitioners that are working at healing somebody's gut don't necessarily put them on high-dose glutamine for a long period of time anyhow.
So a couple of weeks on a higher dose glutamine to try to heal the gut can be beneficial.
This glutamine heals the gut because it stimulates growth, stimulates growth, regrowth of new epithelial cells that lie in the gut.
So it helps grow new cells while it helps grow new cells.
You have cancer cells in the gut or something too.
So it also depends slightly on the type of cancer.
If the person was dealing with colon cancer and they might be in full remission from colon cancer, I don't think I'd ever use glutamine.
But if they're dealing, if they had breast cancer and they're in full remission, then I think using glutamine for a short period of time is fine.
There's other things a person can do to heal their gut without using glutamine.
So there's tons of different herbs that are gut healing herbs that are not going to stimulate growth too, so something to look into those things too.